in the best of times even when I was
world number one for many many weeks and
months in a row at certain times during
the year I said what can I improve what
do I need to change because if you don't
do anything or you just do the same
thing over and over again you stay the
same and staying the same means going
backwards because the other guys are
working hard and improving so I always
needed to find ways to improve my game
as well I don't think it's enough just
to love it and then just to do it and go
out and win it it's not that simple you
need to have structured goals you need
to tell yourself okay what are my goals
for
the short term what are my goals for the
long term now that I've accomplished
almost everything
um I'm supposed to go out on the tennis
court thinking let's just pay free it's
just hit the ball who cares you know but
this is not how you're going to win
matches because it comes down to margins
and you have to be
um so clear in your mind exactly what
you want to do and what you want to
achieve and for me it doesn't work
without any goals without any Targets I
cannot compete properly it's okay to
lose like him probably too it's okay to
lose but you still want it badly so and
I think that combination got me the win
tonight then that's where confidence can
help in a big big way because you might
be actually not feeling great physically
or mentally you're drained but the
confidence somehow Gets You Through and
when you don't have confidence that's
then when you have to
um
sort of trust all the hard work you've
done and you have to keep on working
hard so success comes back so that's
that's when it becomes tricky I think
when confidence sort of totally leaves
you or you doubt your confidence you
know so how I stay motivated I think for
me it's actually quite easy because I
get a chance to play on Center Courts
around the world
um I've seen a lot of the places many
times so I have a lot of friends that I
have in each City that I visit and then
training that's where I think it's most
challenging to make trainings exciting
so I try to sometimes practicing new
places have fun practice partners and I
think the team's super crucial for me
you know they are the ones that tell me
let's do the running let's do the
jumping let's do the you know this
exercise in tennis today this is what we
do in treatment today and all these
things make it uh so worthwhile then and
then if you win a little bit it's uh
it's more fun
My overall game I have to come to the
net I have to try to finish I have to
try to take chances to me it seemed like
there was more positives than negatives
and if my dream was really to become a
professional tennis player maybe I felt
I should do it even though I was had a
great setup in in Baseline at home and
then when I went it was very exciting
scary in some ways because I was only 14
years old and I was in a foster family
from Monday to Fridays and only came
home on the weekends and I remember you
know crying and on the train and I knew
I was not going to see my family for you
know for five days and then I came back
on Friday I was so happy finally when I
could leave again so the first six
months were were pretty brutal actually
I'm not sure if my goal was to play
pretty or play Beautiful you know I
wanted to win I want I'm a winner and
that that's what the purpose is if I
play tennis is I go out there and I play
good tennis and I try to entertain the
crowd yeah it's difficult to get used to
that you know recognition and the
awareness that everybody might know you
but and especially in this day and age
with social media and everybody having a
phone almost with pictures it becomes
tricky you know but I think I've been
able to remain the person I am and I
stay very grounded so I don't see that
sex symbol kind of guy anyway and I
don't feel that way I feel like a normal
guy who who just happens to be quite
successful but it has to start with your
family and they've given me everything
you know on my way and they've given me
the opportunity and I at the end I guess
I believe that could do it because of
the people around me so I'm I'm happy I
listen to them it's very important to
sort of move on and I think also losses
make you stronger it's important to
learn out of those mistakes and then you
become better and better player you work
harder you know a light goes up in your
head and you're like you know what I
think I understand now what I need to
improve being number one in the world
and you know having the pressure sort of
everybody expecting me to win and I I
think I handle it well and that's why I
don't put myself under extra pressure
and I really hope I can do well and
that's that's really how I look at
things and not going crazy about all the
different types of wreck but it's nice
playing for them or against them
sometimes it tends to get a little bit
much you know you have red carpet
sponsors media tends to get a little
much for you know a person but I think I
handled it well and uh I I always said
if I become them on the world I'm going
to actually start to work harder that's
exactly what happened and I think it
paid off and I'm still here today so
it's just great but I think I was able
to play the way I play today because of
my fitness because of of my physical
efforts I've put into it I I wasn't I
could not believe the balls I would be
able to to catch you know on the court
through Fitness and I feel like that
connected everything the moment I became
physically strong I would get to balls I
didn't know I could get to and then with
my talent and my hand the eye
coordination and my technique I was able
to pull off shots I never thought I
could and I think this is when it when
it got really a lot of fun for me that's
when tennis went into overdrive I
believe so
um you have to find your own identity
and do it your way but you can look at
them what they did so good and maybe use
that for your Technique or for your for
your game and I think I did that very
well
I've done so much better than I ever
thought I would that it's it's almost
strange for me to talk about what more
do you want or or what have you done
that really like surprised you because
there's basically everything I've done
so it has surprised me because uh I do
come from a small village in Switzerland
and we don't think that big you know
I've done so much more than all of that
that anything I do right now is just
incredible but obviously at one point
you get used to winning so much and then
you're like okay there's certain things
I would like to reach it's just happy to
play tennis and uh
spend time with my friends really and it
ended here so it's been a been a perfect
journey I would do it all over again
very rare in this day and age I think we
actually almost appreciated that the
other person exists and plays so well
because it actually brings the best uh
out of you and I've been had I had a
harder time when more and more Rivals
were coming up because I always thought
I don't need those guys I I'm just happy
to dominate and play so well but it's
it's nice having all these group of guys
at the top right now I guess you do have
incredible confidence in yourself
sometimes but then also big doubts
whereas if you see another player all
you see is the strengths and weaknesses
as a you know more just like on the
surface so you don't know truly how
confident the horror how worried he is
about his own game so sometimes it's a
bit of a you know a chess game or I
don't want to say you pretend like
you're super fit or you're super uh you
know tired you know you try to maybe
sort of fake the guy out a little bit
you know because what the other guy sees
might affect the way he plays but at the
end of the day I just try to play tough
and fair and then made a better guy win
it was only myself who could tell myself
now Roger you have to come down
otherwise it's not gonna
so it's not gonna last because you're
losing weight much energy so I stopped
and I'm really focused working on your
weaknesses makes maybe an overall
complete player but you won't be
dangerous anymore you know you can
sometimes relate to that in some
businesses as well that's why I like to
work on the strength and it's really
helped me through throughout my career
I'm happy I started so early I was able
to learn a lot in the beginning of my
career through being in on the big stage
in the big moment meeting very
influential and important people who
have taught me great things you know my
mom has been the big inspiration behind
me starting my own Foundation at a very
young age and here we reached that 10
years of the foundation we've reached I
think the lies about 86 000 kids so far
with quality education and I feel I
really still feel at the beginning and I
hope we can achieve great things